how's the gum res one is welcome freakin
welcome goddamn welcome you're so
[ __ ] welcome to South Park the stick
of truth I along with a lot of a lot of
people are so excited with this game I
think the concept is really cool
they went for making a software game
that actually feels like you you're part
of the TV show
like the actual show I remember when I
was younger and I played games based on
that animated films or whatever and
there's always this awkward 3d rendered
characters and it's not really what you
want what you really want is to play the
shows so they come up with this genius
idea with South Park the stick of truth
and it just sounds [ __ ] amazing
there's no wonder this game is so hyped
I just feel so lucky to have the game
here I'm just so [ __ ] excited to play
it let's see if it's good or bad or
[ __ ] awesome I hope for the last one
let's find out hope you bros will join
me on this I think it will be a long
journey but I think will be a stick of
truth one I don't know what I meant by
that but it doesn't matter let's go that
is a upside-down lemon with a hat that
soul is a win it's like looks like we're
back in the 90s or it's a porno I hope
the last one again [ __ ]
his foes as the humans begged their King
to save them a noble King known only as
the Grand Wizard those are the animation
sale the drow elk armies continued their
attack but the tides of war ensued
estranged and as news of a new kid
spreads throughout - then in order to
save the humans the Grand Wizard must
get to the new kid before the drought
helps to manipulate his name and use him
to take the sacred relics in human hands
but whomever control controls the
universe just like real life
just like real life
[ __ ] yeah so we're actually the new kid
or whatever and that's what the story
based upon and it's heavily Lord of the
Rings inspired in case you even realize
spray tan of course way Jersey nice
all that has glitter and [ __ ] I think a
little spray pain
I don't spray that no matter no ok let's
go with it what happened don't question
me you weren't well that doesn't matter
so the question is you to make a guy
that looks like a [ __ ] [ __ ] or if it
looks like us I guess it doesn't really
matter it's practically the same thing
so yeah I think that kinda looks like my
hair what do we were in school I always
wore like [ __ ] hoodies and [ __ ] I
don't really wear any much anymore but
hey I'm younger here I guess what should
we go with a clean smooth face yes nope
what there has to be a good one what
about the butt cheek I have a little bit
of a chicken Cape either than I realize
let's go in our nice
eyewear is for [ __ ] for that costume
are just for looks each costume provides
I can't how am I supposed oh nice nice
it smells good man I was so excited for
this game and keep saying man man
[Music]
this is our home
well I think that's everything we did it
hon we're really moved in it's a new
beginning for us things are finally
going to be good do you really think it
will be better for him
thank you I won't look for him here we
just need to make sure he doesn't
attract any attention come on
let's see how he's doing sweetie
hon y'all dressed uh yeah I'm doc come
in I goddamn it how do you like your new
room
it's pretty [ __ ] gay I know it's a
big change for all of us but son do you
remember why we moved to this quiet
little mountain town I don't know he
doesn't remember
he doesn't remember at all that's good
that's good he doesn't remember ah
sweetie we want you to have lots of fun
here why don't you go out and make some
friends right get outside and play son
like like normal kids we've got some
money for you on the kitchen counter
sweetie just be back before it gets dark
yeah we love you too but what a shitty
parents your son your son has to be
normal what is this what is this okay
fine son gives us a play win that's
[ __ ] great that's fun you can fire on
anything you like it's on the left
[ __ ] miles bud
that's fantastic man inventory okay oh
hey that fishy you're so nice you are my
best friend you know how much I love you
this much you're welcome
what do we got in here my turn to fill a
backpack knife five what the hell
alright fine I'm so gonna abuse that by
the man pants I wonder what's in that
box
guess well never now so I guess this is
how I would look like if I was a South
Bay keiki hey dad so much what you don't
like it oh come on man
stinky but it was just for you when we
dissent pain oh what a thing it wasn't a
request it was a command now get out
there and make some friends [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] parents mang I just want
to play video games or farlen [ __ ] hello
it's [ __ ] high level maturity on this
game Matt I love it oh I thought I could
knock them over
Oh I'm giving a quest to my bad okay you
and your parents just move to South Park
they just want okay go outside fine okay
fine
hi Fred you suck butters man
that's right kill him kill him
take that and that and that we should be
friends I have a new friend he does when
you leave your first dear friend in some
[ __ ] messages from your friends will show
up here on your home page till your
friends you made click on the
collectibles tab cool see collect
friends in the greenhouse over there
it's just like the prophecy foretold
makes me excited it makes me wanna
Canada space it's okay I guess why are
we here like this what's wrong with my
[ __ ] yet God please don't
what's wrong my [ __ ] hat ha it's
fabulous
okay you don't know do you know how much
more I could go into this half a second
so you are the new kid your coming was
foretold by Coldwell Banker I am the
wizard King but the time for talk is not
NAT let me show you my kingdom I [ __ ]
love this so far it feels so cool it
really is like what they said it it
feels like I'm wearing Cartman's house
shut up man not now hey don't talk to
your mom like that that's Road oh my
hi is that Spanish do you see oh my god
bless Pontiacs Spanish they say oh my
you like huh is that Spanish
welcome to the kingdom of Koopa keep
that's pretty [ __ ] awesome
big innit our weapons shop here is
tended by Clyde a level 14 warrior damn
14 you can see our massive stables
overseen by the level 9 ranger Scott
malkinson who has the power of diabetes
and here of course is the breathtaking
and lovely princess King the fairest
maiden in all the kingdom don't ask why
can you want it to be a chick it's just
how he seemed to be really right now oh
man this [ __ ] game okay
I missed the South Park humor oh Shannon
me to punch in Maya Kenny I must say you
look quite how are you tonight okay so
let's talk to these people
that's right you may have heard of my
deeds at the Battle of start spot what
that's the line the grand wizard gave me
oh sorry but the grand wizard told me to
stick to the script that's okay that's
the line the grand wizard gave me what
is he gonna say as my diabetes the power
of diabetes is both a gift and a curse
the kraang grizzy withhold snacks if we
talk off the bed fix your legs
no talking Scott you have been sought
out new kid because humans everywhere
are in great danger I need something
from you and in return I'm prepared to
allow you into my kingdom I know you are
very excited it's time for your first
quest but first please tell us thy name
ah finally they asked for my name my
name it's poor no the man known the
Fantana left no wood
you interred douchebag is that correct
[Music]
yes are you sure you want to keep the
name douchebag
no very well just beg you will now
choose a sacrifice rich beef au jus avid
you gotta go with it do you have so I
guess we'll never really be friends come
on you Jersey
so you're basically cows Marc you come
from New Jersey
I mean fighters courage honor and the
ability to kick [ __ ] how do you think
breast I feel I have to be the Jew I'm
age it's like a wizard only not as COO
why do they have it then you look sneaky
enough to be a thief Thanks I mean you
got a rolled you man
you just got a rolled you man now please
go and visit the weapon shop procure
yourself a weapon and we shall teach you
to fetch this gave me some [ __ ]
awesome biters of living okay I can do
it
would you like to see my wares weary
traveler perhaps you would like to hear
tips and rumors for two dollars nah I
want to buy a weapon no I want to buy a
weapon a jury staff huh yes a lovely
purchase thank you
now how do I equip it drag it there we
go have a clean ah you have procured a
weapon yes it's now time to teach you
how to fight I want you to take your new
weapon and with the bravery of another
night beat up that one chick that you
kid what I do I'm the King clan and the
King wishes to be amused go on new kid
kick a desk really [ __ ] looks like me
that guy I'm gonna kick your ass
glad you have to wait your turn that's
lame no clad it's like olden times you
have to wait your turn
like in the Middle Ages time I know it's
lame clad but that's how we're [ __ ]
doing it alright douchebag backlash
Bayesian don't be sad
that's a turn-based RPG huh I didn't
blocking okay
left click to select your action and
then left click on your target surgery
staff on him okay I want you to hit
cloud as hard as you can
yes that's of course when your weapon
physis right click all right
guys with armor like that okay listen up
the key to surviving in battle is not to
get hit in the back glad it's your turn
to attack juice back to protect your
backs
prepare yourself oh dude you already
that's right clay alright it's time to
use your heroic powers using your
ability takes power points or PP for
joint PP if you have a [ __ ] better
day for them to [ __ ] snake eyes
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm the King and I say
it PP douchebag use your Jew ability to
make Clyde pay for insulting the King I
thought it was the grand wizard was his
abilities slug of David casts the first
stone at an enemy deals more damage if
done perfectly I'm [ __ ] sorry sorry
but can lead to self injury if done
improperly okay mash deftly sling of
David it's a sock with what in it
go way to wipe that smile off his stupid
face douchebag
now do it one more time finish him what
I was going easy take dick no no oh sure
he got me what I did wrong
okay well let's just finish that [ __ ]
[Applause]
the power of David okay okay you proved
yourself worthy juice bag now come
inside the words head tonight shall let
you see the ready
that sounds really perverted I'm not
sure I actually want to go in there I
guess I have no choice but it makes me
so excited it makes his eyes I want it
what did you say Ken What did he say
thanks thanks I appreciate that hair
you're welcome
I ordered you into the board can't do
today shut up I'm busy I probably said
you're right to babble it bubbles that
really butters well here it is the
reason why humans and elves are locked
in a never-ending war the relic for
which human and elf are willing to die
the stick of truth [ __ ] really just
two days ago we took the stick back from
the of our kingdom was dang but now its
rise for whoever controls the stick
controls the universe don't get it now
that you have seen the stick of truth
let's discuss your dues being a member
of my kingdom cost 995 for the first
week four dollars of which is
tax-deductible somebody said that is
some real kinky [ __ ] bad gotta fart out
oh oh that's awesome
Oh chicken wings of course what if I
take in ah no don't do something breasts
don't guys gave us awesome Oh No
all right let's go magna gate don't let
them grow give it the stick humans suck
you dry up
come again good guys the stick of truth
while we defend the fortress III heii
we're not playing pirates cried in fact
this is your chance to prove yourself
hold off the [ __ ] hell's at all cost
no no no no stop we bet it Kenneth
touching his business five butters fight
[ __ ] alright let's fight this guy do it
douchebag kick these out that's it I
will sir well oh [ __ ]
[Music]
thanks what is it it's a cheesy pops of
course that heals me thank you
rooster you can have one potion every
turn I asked for five but this was
government
this guy's bastards back try to block
all these attacks alright well there
[Music]
well this job doesn't work out of this
you've got a future as a training dummy
but I get it right you're mine now
there we go we can take the [ __ ] out of
him [ __ ] yeah now finish off these elves
in the name of the Whizzer King alright
sorry I guess
all right fling of David on that [ __ ]
alright 100 buckets do a stat that
[ __ ] oh thank you thank you I
actually like that a combat it's pretty
smooth
I'm surprised come on kick you in your
diabetic nuts
[ __ ] off I love this sequence the
loading sequence
reposting are that yeah what are you
waiting for douche bag that guy's just
standing there go kick his ass bow of
sucking nice what switch to your arrows
snipe it sniped that little [ __ ] huh
all right well I guess now you can juice
back use your arrows take out the archer
do it I dare you can't play anymore
sorry
yeah big [ __ ] with the widget king
careful douchebag that guys ready for
your arrows now you gotta try something
else
what should I try then what about my
balls my balls in the flings I'm David
Ghaffar great job dude thank you I can
still hit them nice takeoff weight so
the kitty is defending is that where
Jimmy Bob you will pay for this let's do
this bag in the name of Kitty [ __ ] his
repassing
oh no he's in stop it what are you
alright
alright Joey stop go let it down now's
your chance now attack his armor oh my
god block Oh in the butt
yes huh [ __ ] yeah bras
fall back fall back I say
Kenny's looking so fab we still control
its God what the stick of truth
bells got it
that was your one goddamn job dad to
guard the stick of sucking truth
glad you are hereby banished from space
and time
what no you can't do that yeah I can
you're banished and lost in time in
space yeah go home glad you fought
bravely on the battlefield through space
you can make your camp nice
shut up nobody cares what you think the
stick of truth has been stolen and we
must assemble our entire army in order
to get it back
let's need that boy you haven't reported
for duty my king our newest member can
take care of that douche bag
I want you to go out into the
neighborhood and find my greatest
warriors token tweek and Craig I'm
texting their pictures to your personal
inventory device now but beware the
lands outside are full of marauding drow
elfs monsters and sixth-graders be sure
you're well-equipped now go and send my
warriors here fighters go with him I
like that they don't introduce all the
characters right away like all the
famous one we don't have candy butters
and Cartman so far which is pretty cool
all right Timmy
take me Express nice sir Timmy's fast
travel that's a nice horse right there I
must say it's quite the delicate Hoss
all right fine tweets fine token I
remember token hey guy what's that
oh my is that Spanish Terrence but it's
good okay so having to us bow let's try
the jiu-jitsu utilize this a secret
Jewish marginal height is that really
true is that true if you're Jewish
please please inform me because then I
wouldn't know about it I'm not trying to
make fun of Jews by the way like I
expect all religions it's just seemed
like the coolest class okay I'm just
saying you should be honored totally
totally let's check out Cartman's room
man I want to hope we can go there
that'd be awesome
his room should be here
no ice probably Dale doesn't [ __ ] in
here yep
black thunder nice and I can sell that
[ __ ] but magic is my favorite nothing
now okay all right they drugs and dildos
in Lube that's Antonio Banderas love
doll if I can take only that one where
can I use this [ __ ] or what do I just
solid I can equip it because if I can
equip it that's this [ __ ] amazing
yeah I don't care oh man this [ __ ]
game I'm gonna love this [ __ ]
that's me here there we go what exactly
are you looking for maybe you should see
a doctor
what did you say did I think so oh yeah
those I remember there's semen episode
oh man ah Brad Pitt survival gear okay
that's sure that will be coming handy
[Music]
naari
so it has in the closet awesome also
many references man he does it isn't it
that's awesome yeah this is pretty quite
well let's do our quest because we have
a couple of them look for Craig
let's do Craig first no token actually I
don't know let's just do whatever I
don't think it matters
so where do we go we aren't allowed to
go into the street make such an open
world up there so let's get her Magic
Mike Rose about you yeah I'd sit by
farts hello ginger kid you're good at
that
I thank you no one ever complimented it
wizard K says I'm too ginger to be one
of the humans but how Adam butters lets
me be a squire on the sly yes you're
okay in my book series I mean your
hearts reach you'd let me go
yes I will yes I where can I break this
now that I'm a piled powerful Jew love
this soundtrack you two again here I'm
sorry I just like exploring sometimes on
oh yeah I want to check the side power
potion alright thank you no humans [ __ ]
yeah
why do we got here
[Music]
yeah that's a beautiful horse man how
does it okay alright so I think we're
gonna have to class I think it's perfect
location to stop this virgin episode as
I've said way too many times repeating
myself with this game it looks really
cool I hope you boys will join me in
this journey please leave a like if you
want to support this series I really do
appreciate it it helps keeping it alive
and all that good stuff I think you both
so much for watching it I can't wait to
share more of this with you see when
that episode tomorrow it's a breakfast
for you thousand brothers love you
[Music]